ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show we are here is late Thursday
night early Friday morning in the studio
we are doing a lot of stuff we got the
TBS tournament of laughs coming up that
we made a video for me and Benjamin
we're going against I don't know I think
Godfrey who's a phenomenal comedian and
maybe will advance I don't know if
that's all you I don't know if they're a
judge I really don't I didn't I haven't
paid attention and TBS executives have
tweeted they've called me and they're
like why aren't you tweeting anything
out and I just I'm like listen it is
what it is don't you do any of the
marketing Network
do you do any of the marketing for the
show one of the executive producers like
maybe Joe Rogan I'll talk about it I'm
like maybe who is that are you trying to
tell me something maybe he will you know
if he likes the show maybe you'll bring
it up I don't know let's get to the most
I want to say pressing matter but it's
really not in the world of you know
civil unrest pandemics and economic
catastrophes but it is a pressing matter
and it is something people have a lot of
interest in and it is something that
everybody's kind of talking about this
week and it does affect LA and it is
serious and it is something that I want
to talk about and it's something I've
talked about before on this show and
that it is that ocean prime is back open
there's Steakhouse ocean prime which is
a lot of good seafood and it's in
Beverly Hills and I think that it's back
open on the patio now they do you have
inside dining but they're encouraging
people to go on the patio and I think
that's important it's important that
people go back out on the patio and be
careful but also enjoy yourself
ocean prime is also of course offering
curbside to go that's I'm kidding that's
a joke
that's a joke of course story I'm
talking about is a lot of people are
trying to recall Gavin Newsom
the Governor of California and people
said to me where are you on this and you
know he's you know he's about decent
looking and he's done it fair you know
whatever he's a little drunk on his own
power but who is it you know I was
watching this there's a great this is
show on Netflix called you have you seen
this why are you laughing
have you seen this show on Netflix yeah
yeah called
you it's the guy from Gossip Girl Penn
Badgley Bagley I don't know how to say
his name and and he plays a serial
killer and the first episode is in
Brooklyn the first season is in Brooklyn
and the second season is in Los Angeles
California and I was watching this show
and this show is very fun to watch I
mean it is you get it's I mean it's not
fun to live I imagine but it is fun to
watch I mean it is a very watchable show
it's a very watchable show um and you
know who's in it you know who's in the
show comedian do you know he's in the
show is it Chris D'Elia
no it's comedians act cherry can you
google Zach check Google sec cherry
Christmas in it as well
Google Zach this is the big guy
comedians actuary you know say he's a
big boy but he's a fun man chris is in
it as well what does Chris play in the
show a pedophile well he plays a
comedian who is into an underage girl
here's the thing folks he plays
character name Henderson I've spoken to
crystally about three times in my life
they've all been in the Comedy Store and
he's been very pleasant to me now that
is not a defense and that it's not me
trying to qualify anything I'm gonna say
here but I will say that Chris has been
very kind to me and he's said that I'm
very funny and that does count a little
bit it does not a lot not it doesn't
excuse what is shaping up to be some
very disturbing allegations but he's
always been very nice to me chris is one
of those guys who took a real famous
comedian like when you look at his
Instagram it's like Machine Gun Kelly
would comment he did the thing with
Eminem he's like the LA comic right he's
like Bieber's favorite comic right like
Bieber will go to the store right yes
yeah it's everything in comedy that like
I am I am NOT that like I am not like
the guy that's cool who has a fan base
that's cool you know what I mean like
the last person to retweet something I
did was really big was Candace Owens so
let's just you know I'm like not a cool
comic and Chris is a cool comic no not
that that has done uncool things but I
mean like but he's very sweet to me
listen everybody knew the dude got laid
we just knew he got laid because his fan
base was women women would attack him in
the whole of the comedy store they would
run up to him I'm not saying I'm not
saying that they are but I'm saying from
my own eyes I would see like women go up
to him and like he was like women don't
come up to me after the set and go thank
God I saw you in fours with my
girlfriend you're so high your tits are
so hot I saw it in fours you saw ha that
doesn't really have like that's not the
type of comic I am sadly it would be
nice if I was like you know pulling up
in a hawk
I usually get out of an uber seriously a
frustrated Asian man I don't know I
don't know if the minivan Doors
automatic then why even ever hit but
that's so listen it's just [ __ ] a lot
of chicks that are of age and they're
mad at you it's it's on them
right I mean listen women have agency
women are smart women can make choices
now if those women are underage that's a
serious problem it's a legal problem
it's a moral problem it's an ethical
problem and I imagine if more of that
comes out it's gonna be dealt with in a
court which is where you know
unfortunately you know should be dealt
with because that is criminal activity
if you're 19 and you're mad because you
know you know the guy whose hotel room
you went to it's ray I'm turned out not
to be a gentleman this is a learning
experience for all involved but if
you're underage and your message that is
[ __ ] not right and that'll be dealt
with in a court of law
I would imagine or you know it's also
dealt with in the court of public
opinion where people go somebody who's
doing that he's just not somebody that
people want to do business with anymore
or establish a friendship with you know
I you know I hope that stuff isn't true
but you know I when I was on keto I
hoped that that would work do you see
what I mean you know Obama used to say
hope is a powerful thing
not really it's not that powerful facts
gravity immutable laws those things
occasionally fly in the face of hope so
I hope
I did that is there is no truth to the
allegations if he was messaging underage
girls now it does seem that sadly my
hope is not going to stand up against
and by the way I hope that for everyone
involved I hope it for the girls opened
for him I hope that like that's not
going on am I gonna get a better spot at
the store because he won't be there
let's be honest yes I'm not I'm not
gonna lie I mean we came over it might
not be but I'm kidding we're kids
economy show we're doing a comedy
podcast and I wish everyone well here's
a reality it's a bad situation for a lot
of people that knew him that are very
disappointed and disgusted and you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] I bet that guy
he sadly has a lot of demons a lot of
things that he's fighting and it's a
whole thing's bad whole thing is no good
naked but everything I'm involved in is
destroyed I got into subprime mortgages
they would we you know we had a
recession Adam McKay was producing a
show of mine and then he dissolved his
company with Will Ferrell Gary Sanchez
Anthony Bourdain's company was producing
my travelogue with Comedy Central and he
hung himself in a room several days
later my agent who signed me in 2016 is
no longer working at the agency that
signed me I mean I tend to get into the
party as the party is break it up I tend
to arrive at the party as the cop cars
are being seen through the window and
this is maybe literally now but that's
when I get to the party and that's
unfortunate so if I walk in I mean it's
countdown till something's gonna
go down and it's not gonna be good so
again I feel for the firt for the
victims of this like the women that were
messaged and were made to feel
uncomfortable that were underage that is
illegal and that is wrong I do not feel
for the comedians who are complaining
that they don't get better spots III
think it's a little disgusting to try to
weave your own personal narrative into
this and your own gripes and your
problems Chris kill whether you like his
comedy not Chris killed
he killed harder at the store than
anyone I've ever seen I mean he earned
his spots at The Comedy Store he had
theaters of thousands of people coming
to see him I mean whether you liked his
comedy or not it doesn't matter people
did and they came to see him and he made
money so the comics that are out there
now and they did this with Louie they
did this with everybody they come out go
ducks
whose dog there's not even good at
comedy like me it's not gonna call me
like miss alright man get online create
your own [ __ ] and you know it's [ __ ]
stop whining you know but I mean this is
Thursday night early Friday morning more
may come out more is may come out um I
would imagine that this rocks things a
little bit here in this town um I've
only been here a year seems like it may
be time to start thinking about pizza
again and the Hudson River if we could
get de Blasio out of there get the cove
it out in the de Blasio up maybe I'll
Wallace back I think Rogen's teasing
that he's moving to another state Chris
seems unfocused at the moment cuz he'd
be the next biggest act so I don't know
what's gonna happen out here but you
know see me hears me there he goes
every goes see him just one taco one
last taco yeah you know I feel bad for
you know the women that were affected
you know I mean this is shitty and I
don't know facts this is the other thing
I've not done a deep dive on the facts
doesn't mean I'm doubting people and not
believing them I'm saying I have not
personally looked into this at all have
you looked at any of the facts really I
mean facts I mean I guess anything could
be photoshopped right I mean these are
just screenshots I mean the idea that
all these people are coming together and
photoshopping a bunch of things seems to
be do you think it's the Russians do you
think it's the Russians
it's Russian Bob do you think it's these
two Chinese it will be and I'm not
saying that he should do this but it
would be beyond funny if he came out and
said this was Russia yeah like if he
came out and he said first they install
Donald drop the puppet
then they manufacture a bunch of
screenshots and take me down goddamn
them the Russians Putin [ __ ] you Putin I
don't want to laugh folks I don't want
to laugh because people are getting it
angry with me for laughing they're gonna
go sure I know it's a serious situation
but I deal with serious situations with
humor it's you know I just have to laugh
but and you know but it's it's you know
wherever it goes it goes I don't know
what to tell you you know you know it
probably was not Russia I don't know or
China yeah I imagine it wasn't China I
mean it seems legit
it it's it's unfortunate that this is
happening you know there's so much good
news in the country by the way this is
like the entertainment news right said
the good news is so bad now they're like
this is entertainment news you know
they're like any in the entertainment
corner this is the fluff right this is
the light-hearted fluff news that you
get if he was doing that it's so weird
to take that role on that show you on
Netflix it's very strange to take that
role he imagined like taking that role
if you were doing that like as if to say
how could I be doing this if I did take
this role yeah you imagine that you have
the script and you're like Jesus Jesus
this is good but that's you know that's
kind of what we're gonna say about that
there's no no new facts about it yet um
and you know we're gonna withhold I'm
not the judge in the jury but I am
someone in the courtroom sitting around
eating potato chips who's gonna talk
share after the trial so that's what I'm
doing
I don't know the facts I haven't done a
deep dive the facts are disturbing that
are coming out you know um and that's
where I'll leave it you know a lot a lot
bigger people are gonna have something
to say about this I'm sure people that
um well slabs and friends and whatever
you know I don't know it's like what do
you think the implications are about
this why don't you make a statement why
do I make god [ __ ] stay I have to
make a stay why don't you make a
statement
where's Jamie Vernon on this where's all
the other producers you guys [ __ ] sit
and listen everything everybody says and
then you don't have to have a goddamn
stay we all got to come out with
statements you're in the [ __ ] room
for everything that we all say and
nobody says anything huh so you want me
to have a take on it well what's your
statement what's your take my take is
that it's bad to be a pedophile that's
it
but he's not a pedophile our pheeba file
it's bad to be at a feeble file get the
word up please
now I'm not gonna correct people on
Twitter it seems like an odd Hill to die
on I think Neil I think Neal Brennan was
doing it feel Brennan was like in the
middle of the night be like it's a Heber
file I just woke up I looked at my phone
oh my god what's this guy doing Neil put
your phone down the [ __ ] are you doing
it's actually a Hiba fires or what hey
Neil Hiba thelia is a primary sexual
interest in mid to late adolescence
generally ages 15 and 19 it's a number
it is one of a number of sexual
preference across age groups subsumed
under the technical term
Crona feel yeah I don't know that means
what is a Hiba file is that somebody
likes Jews he view file what's that
what's a hebrew file see somebody likes
Jews somebody who's attracted to men and
large hats with beards who own who own
projects in Brooklyn people attract
people I'm attracted to men with beards
who own low-income housing in
Williamsburg what are you or your a Eva
file
um I don't know okay well listen there
you have it folks I mean that's Ben's
[ __ ] statement you know nice and
simple is it all over the news
it's all over the news right yeah I mean
when you type in his name into Twitter
it seems like there's still like 20
tweets a minute I'd say and there's
still news articles about it so it's up
there but you know he was trending at
the same time that world war 3 was
trending so you know right there's just
so much going on there's a lot going on
here I go I grab the the burrito there
it goes
Delta is that you going up the plane
yeah it's walking up the plane as I
leave Los Angeles gets bombed by China I
[Music]
just wave I land in New York I just put
a pizza I just take a bite of pizza and
I'm like it's New York you know what are
you gonna do well all right everybody
we're gonna continue to record the rest
of the episode tomorrow I just I felt
like I should address this tonight and
you know maybe tomorrow everything I
said will be if they start finding
bodies you know if they find like 10
bodies we will they find 10 bodies I'm
sitting there like tomorrow to come in
like this I'm like ah what if the Andrew
Santino kills his wife tonight I gotta
come in and I gotta be like ah Tony
Hinchcliffe gets drunk he kills a family
of four on the 405 I'm like you know uh
Whitney coming bludgeons our dog to
death I'm like you know I have to make a
four statements that make four
statements today
all right folks we will continue this
shortly this episode of the Timbaland
show is sponsored by blue - guys
remember the days when you're always
ready to go now you can increase your
performance get the extra confidence in
bed listen out blue true calm that's
like the color blue blue true brings you
the first tuba with the same
fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis you keep take them any
time day or night even on a full stomach
and since they're chewable they work up
to twice as fast as a pill so you could
be ready whenever an opportunity arises
you could benefit from confidence when
it counts right blue chew is fast and
easy way to enhance your performance
with some body of legal age bluetooth
prescribes online by licensed physician
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package to get you ready for a
consensual encounter with someone of
legal age they're made in the USA it
says blue chip repairs at ships direct
are cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all there's no more awkwardness
especially because both of you are of
legal age right now we've got a special
deal for our listeners visit blue true
calm and get your first shipment free
when you use our promo code t I M just
pay five dollars shipping again that's B
lue CH e w.com promo code Tim to try it
it's free and again that's le g al a GE
the Tim Dylan shows brought to you by
expressvpn Jesus Christ the ads on this
show huh what a week expressvpn is great
for protecting your privacy and security
online Lord Jesus help me God Christ on
the cross help me get through this ad
after this week here's what you're gonna
do on expressvpn
you
gonna use it to unlock foreign movies
and TV shows are only available in other
countries binge Doctor Who on Netflix in
the United Kingdom or watch spirited
away on Netflix in Japan and so much
more it's easy to use just open the app
change your location and that's it
choose from over a hundred different
countries Express VPN works for any
streaming service Netflix Amazon Hulu
BBC YouTube YouTube you name it if a
movie or TV show is streaming somewhere
you can watch it it works on all your
devices any phone tablet console or
smart TV it's fast no buffering or lag
streaming HD without an issue on any
device it's part of your house if you
visit my special link right now
expressvpn dot slash Tim Dylan you can
get an extra three months if expressvpn
for free good deal support the show
watch what you want and protect yourself
expressvpn dot-com slash Tim Dylan TI M
di ll o n it is a private what is it the
VPN I know what it is but I'm just
saying having use Virtual Private
Networks it's a virtual private network
so you are not tracked and traced by the
government so there you have it
expressvpn you know I mean the ads on
this show this week have been I mean I
don't even know what to say at this
point right now I I do not even I don't
know what to say
we've had blue Chu and the virtual
private network that we are pitching
here let's hopefully we have something
wholesome coming up but this is awesome
you're using it to watch Doctor Who yes
only that yes on Netflix that's why
you're going to the expressvpn okay to
watch Doctor Who
Express VPN comm / Tim Dylan alright
everybody we are back here Friday the
next day we did we did a little intro
the beginning of the show we shot last
night Thursday night we covered the
D'Elia situation and not much has
changed in 24 hours now of course we are
digging up podcast clips from Joey Diaz
and Brogan and we're trying to you know
we're doing what we do as a species
which is try to try to see how many
people we could put in the net this is
how we emerged from quarantine we
emerged from quarantine not stronger not
stronger when was my favorite thing is
well we shut down the entire economy and
there were people on TV going we're all
gonna come out of this much stronger
we're gonna really realize what's
important and by what's important we
mean what was said on a podcast in 2011
that's what me we mean when we get out
of this quarantine we're gonna we're
gonna really focus on what really
matters what really matters you know
your family your health and what Joey
Diaz said on a podcast seven years ago
that's what really matters that's how we
came out of quarantine very strong you
know comedy is is is getting to the
point where I you know I was talking to
Louis Gomez the other day and Louis made
a really good point
he said he's think we got five years
left in the business and what he meant
by that and I think he was right is that
within five years the type of comedy
that we do is just going to become it's
gonna fly in the crosshairs of Google
and YouTube and a lot of these big
platforms and they're going to just kind
of do everything they can to get
and at that point you'll you know go to
a smaller platform you know or you'll
just say [ __ ] it okay you know I had my
run I had fun made some money you know
but the tide is is turning when it comes
to the types of comedy that people even
want you know younger people don't want
the type of comedy that might upset
anybody and I don't really have an
interest in doing the type of comedy
that you know younger people want right
now I don't you know it's not for me so
I'm just gonna keep doing what I do
until it's impossible to do but but that
could be coming sooner rather than later
and I mean I'll always have some level
of you know podcast you can broadcaster
I'll go on the road you know to the
extent that I want to go on the road we
do have new dates on sale right now in
August we have I'm gonna be at the
Sacramento punchline it's the last
weekend of July into August Sacramento
punchline
okay so Friday July 31st through
Saturday August first Sacramento
punchline I'm gonna be a wiseguys in
Salt Lake City Utah Friday August 7th
and 8th Cleveland hilarities Thursday
August 13th through the 15th and then
the Ontario improv the 27th through the
30th of August if you're healthy and you
want to go out and you're sick of
sitting at home and you're sick of
sifting through the podcasts of you know
people to try to find things they've
said that are upsetting and you want to
get out and breathe some fresh air in a
mask which I love now the way everyone's
getting mad at Rogan because of the mask
and it's like how many things about this
virus have been reversed how many they
said it lived on surfaces and then they
said no didn't sorry we didn't mean that
they said asymptomatic carriers could
could really transmit the virus now they
said
actually not really it's pre-symptomatic
which means you'll get symptoms
eventually and for a few days you may
not have the symptoms but in terms of
asymptomatic people people that never
have symptoms we don't know how much
that you know they've they've revised
the mortality rate a bunch so I'm not
saying you know don't wear a mask in a
business or if you're around other
people it seems smart to however it's
very possible they come out here in a
few weeks and go oh yeah by the way the
masks were you know no good or the masks
were not as effective as we thought we
thought ventilators were great in the
beginning and then we realized they were
killing people and you know who knows
who knows where they say about the masks
but like let's not treat anything as
Dogma because we love doing that we love
hearing something in conga this is the
way it is now and then a week later we
realized that that wasn't the case and
then we you know we we just throw it
away and pretend it never happened
[ __ ] forget it pretend it never
happened like when these protests
started happening we just pretend we
weren't supposed to not gather in groups
of 10,000 people just forgot that we
pretended that did it wasn't a thing so
yeah but I will be back on the road in
August unless the spikes are crazy and
like you know it's dangerous to go out I
don't I don't know I can't predict it
I'm not going to predict it you know I
I'm not going to predict it but you know
this is you know when you when you go on
Twitter and and most of you don't and
you shouldn't but the amount of people
that call themselves comedians is
hilarious like this any other group of
people have such a lacks definition of
who is and who is in a comedian how many
people out there saying they're a model
with no evidence of it I'm sure some but
how many people call themselves a model
and have never modeled and are grotesque
you know disgust
I mean how many people are doing that
maybe more than I know are people doing
that a B people with like lesions on
their face sit down with a group of
other people go by model actually I
because there's so many people that are
comedians and all of them have been
robbed they're all geniuses one at all
they are phenomenal no one better than
these guys and they've all been robbed
by somebody somebody took their
opportunity away I had nothing to do
with them I had nothing to do with the
fact it's just a very difficult thing to
pursue it was all the cards were stacked
against them and all these people do all
day is attack people that have succeeded
I mean it's boring at this point yeah I
mean you read it you go through it you
scroll through it you're like yeah guys
you see where these people live they
don't even live in New York or LA yeah
I'm in Denver I'm in Denver and I have
the career I should add the [ __ ] out of
Denver but it doesn't matter it's not
rational you know but it's just it's why
maybe there's minami Lewis we're talking
abouts like five years left it's like
you almost wanted to say to some of
these people and some of the people that
are losing their minds could buy and
sell me some of them have so much money
it's it's wild how much money some of
these people have and they still are
oppressed its IIIi don't know how it
happens like there's still oppressed
with all the money in the world it's
still at I still can't get out of bed
they can't go to a comedy club there
everything it because it's just you know
they have to just if they go to a comedy
club on their way into the comedy club
they just have to fight off rapists
to get inside these people you know tens
of millions of dollars nothing's enough
it's never enough for anyone here never
enough from the open mic or that doesn't
make it to the person who lives in a
mansion
nothing satiates anybody everybody's
constantly battling this invisible force
that is keeping them down at all times
and this force you know takes many
different names you know eventually it
gets boring I mean that's really what it
comes down to it's like I've been in
this business about eleven years I've
seen all of the cycles of people you
know I've seen the people on the outside
become people on the inside and then you
know and then they become the enemy I've
seen that you know I've seen the people
that have all the big opinions get the
jobs and then suddenly they don't have
those opinions anymore
you know it's not interesting you're
just like okay you know you know because
now you know obviously what Chris did
was abhorrent and you know more and more
comes out about that all the time but
like there's this idea that like there's
a crew of people that like support this
kind of behavior or like protect him and
I don't know the guy well and I've never
hung out with them and we've spoke less
than five times but this idea of how
close everybody is is kind of I don't
know where it comes from like I watched
this great documentary about surfing
called
generation momentum generation or
generation moment whatever and it's
about all these servers that essentially
grew up together in this house in Oahu
you have momentum generation and is
about all of these you know Kelly Slater
Rob Machado Shane Dorian these guys are
the best surfers in the world you know
some of them that have ever lived and
it's about how they started out as
teenagers in Hawaii in this small house
in Oahu
they know each other inside and out and
they're all like best friends it's like
a brotherhood and they grew up together
and there's they're they're fiercely
competitive and of course there's they
have issues with each other but they all
become great at this thing together and
it's like I was watching that and I'm
like wow comedies just not this just not
this that's just the reality you know
there are people that are doing comedy
they're very good at it there are people
that are doing it where you go huh
it doesn't matter I mean it's just it
you know some people get very good at it
some people are making millions of
dollars and are still not good at it and
it's just not it's the market decides
right and then that's just what it is
and everybody gets upset at you if you
instead of you you have to suppose you
call out everyone who socks like a what
job does that work what job could you do
that you just go into the office you sit
down you go hey Sarah you suck you suck
sue is much better at a couch receivable
it's not a work environment can't do
that you just go you worry about
yourself you do your own [ __ ] thing
and you're done
really and then you see people every now
and then but this idea that it's like
everybody's super tight and everybody
knows what everybody else is up to it's
like it's not really the case I'm not
saying nobody knows I don't know how
things work but like the idea that like
there's this group of men these
podcasters are keeping me down they are
keeping me down not really
not really also you can start a podcast
or you could do something you know so
it's kind of all I have to say about
that it's a great documentary the
momentum generation it is it is really
cool you know it's such a unique job to
have professional surfer you know it is
a very interesting
thing to do I'm not a surfer and I don't
know anyone who surfs you know because I
tend to I tend to usually only talk to
people that have brain cells so I don't
really speak to people that surf and I
mean there there's very it's a very
impressive athletic feat but these are
not the brightest people they are just
not it's the reality they stand on a
board and you know surf on a wave it's
great but you know this never a surfers
never said something where you've went
wow you know what I mean unless it was
you were like wow that is the dumbest
thing I've ever heard in my life how are
you that dumb but it's fascinating it's
fascinating to just give your entire
life to something like those guys did
that's what's great about the
documentary that's kind of where it
overlaps with comedy you know not in the
sense that we all respect each other's
talent and enjoy each other's presence
but in the sense that for lack of a
better word some of us many of us we we
have dedicated our lives to a thing
right we just got good at one thing it's
kind of crazy when you think about it
like you have your entire life and you
just get good at one thing you know
these surfers got really great at one
thing they woke up in the morning
surfing they go to bed at night [ __ ]
you know spitting up salt water it's
everything they did in their entire life
everything they ate everything they did
every workout they did every
relationship they had every friendship
it was all fit around surfing that is
similar to comedy in the sense that when
you get in you go all-in you go ahead
first and then if it if if it works if
it works and that's a big if okay if it
works it rearranges your entire life
where you live who you're friends with
you know your habits what you do every
day because you have to do it all the
[ __ ] time so as
justing watching that it's like any
sport if you're very good at it
it's a it's a culture as well as its you
know something to spend every day doing
and it was just interesting watching
that there's I don't believe the
healthiest way to live life is that way
by the way I don't believe that to be
but to have a balanced life
is you know the antithesis of what I
just explained you know when you are
dedicated to something you cannot have
any type of balanced life you can't you
got to decide how much you love that
thing
how much you need to be a part of that
thing and it was interesting watching
that documentary because you could see
that there are these people that spent
their entire lives and it define their
lives and like they they they're they'll
never be more at home than when they're
on that surfboard in the water that
that's where they live
it's truly where they live like a comic
being on stage or that's where they're
they live and like most people don't
have that kind of passion they don't
have that kind of passion or if they do
they're not good at it and when you see
all these people on Twitter complaining
about how bad everything is you realize
that like many of them don't even want
to be comedian they don't even get it
they just want something right they want
that community they want something like
I guess there were guys in generation
month like that crew that would just get
out in the ocean and like not even get
up on the board and like after a while
you'd imagine that those people would
leave the beach they'd just leave like
oh it was you know they go have a
California burrito and and figure
something else out but in the
entertainment business you know not
everybody leaves a lot of people stay
they stay and they're angry and they
don't want to do it like most of them
don't even want to do they just want to
have some somebody needs to tell them
they're good at so most people aren't
good at anything I don't know
to tell you you're not good at something
a lot of people waste their lives trying
to get good at something and they still
don't do it and it's like well what'd
you do that for why'd you why'd you
waste your life I mean it's crazy right
you get one life what are you doing
every indication he's showing you you
shouldn't be on a stage telling jokes
and you're not gonna get paid to do that
and whatever you thought this was gonna
be it's not and it doesn't matter and
they still just go [ __ ] it I'm I'm in
I'm in when this quarantine ends they
will flood the clubs again after three
months of no income they will flood them
again they will just go and because they
truly believe that it's gonna now it'll
work now it'll work when half the clubs
are not even opening they're not open
and you know the rooms are socially
distanced and people can't even sit next
to each other and you now it'll beat now
we're now we're now I'm in now it's
gonna fit the pieces are all gonna fit
together now it's a crazy journey when
you dedicate your life to something
because there's the chance that you
won't be good at it and then there's a
chance that you will be good at it and
it won't make you happy even if you're
good at it which is even work many of
these people don't realize even if they
were good at it they wouldn't be happy
because that's not really where
happiness comes for the people that are
doing comedy it's like they're not doing
it to be happy they're trying to be
happy but it's not making them happy you
know anyway it's just what it is
Ansel Elgort being accused of being a
pedophile now he had sex with a 17 year
old when he was 20 I mean what are we
doing now you know I mean I always do
that joke on Twitter where I say I'm
dating out so I'll Gordon go on so all
of our Prokop with me I just want to get
I just want to always get him to
and ER you know call you a call a lawyer
or something Gabby who did not reveal
her last name tweeted a statement on
Friday and made an unverified claim that
the actor now 26 sexually assaulted her
when she was a teenager Gabby describes
sobbing and being a pain it's sad I
didn't want to do it the only words that
came out of his mouth where we need to
break you in well I mean it's you know
I'm gonna I mean here's a deal man was
it good kid 20 and he has sex with a 17
year old I mean is that legal in New
York I don't know I mean I you know I
didn't want the show to be about the age
of consent but it seems a little wild I
mean it's just you know what are we
doing now but it seems a little while to
just say the dude's a pedophile I mean
he seems like a piece of [ __ ] until al
gore do his eyes he's just from a rich
socialite family in New York City his
dad's a photographer I'm not holding any
of that against him but he just has a
face of a guy that's seen a piece of
[ __ ] you know so I'm not like I'm not
defending him per se but I'm just saying
that when someone 17 and somebody's 20
and they hook up calling one of them
pedophile calling the 20 role the
pedophile is crazy hmm
I mean that seems crazy it's like race
everyone's a racist now if you're white
you wait you're racist you wake up
you're racist how you like your pet
latch I mean wait what I mean it's just
like nothing means anything anymore I
don't know maybe it comes out that Ansel
Elgort is doing you know did he you know
sexually assaulted the girl I don't I
believe her I would say I believe her
I've never met her I don't know her and
I've never I didn't even see the
screenshot but let me just believe her I
just want to I want to say that but not
the woman that accused Biden you're
lying or not you not you okay Tara Reid
you lying
you lying [ __ ] I believe but I want to
believe on a gone record
I believe the screenshot we're not the
screenshot I believe the the the the
woman who tweeted about Ansel Elgort
I don't I believe her because I believe
all women I believe old but not Tara
Reid will accuse Biden
I know mm-hmm no I don't believe that
I don't now we have photos of Biden's
sniffing the hair of children and doing
all kinds of weird things to them but
let's not call him a pedophile
let's call I'm so Elgort pedophiles he
hooked up with a 17 year old but not not
Joe Biden who's on camera sniffing the
hair of children and like massaging
children I look let's not let's not jump
to any conclusions about Uncle Joe you
know and I'm sure the woman and I'm sure
the woman Tara Reid who's accusing Biden
is a lying [ __ ] I just wanna I wanna I
just want to be clear on this because I
support women Mets got a great tweet
about this where he said or we I forget
the way he worded it it was great he
goes quick question are we D in in
stating the concept of due process for
chris d'elia that we literally just
reinstated for joe biden after
previously did standing in for all men
please someone I just want to be on the
right side of history
he's got a point he's got a point I'm
not saying that the ly is innocent or
whatever or should even be you know
people should think he's innocent I'd
you know but it's just funny that the
Democratic frontrunner has been like
very credibly accused of sexual assault
but then I guess so is Trump so I guess
it's all like it's a wash right if you
get to run for president or be the
president we just let you rape we just
let you go out it doesn't really matter
it's actors and comedians people like
that but if you're leading the country
you can right below your grab below
right below it's okay but if you're the
guy in baby driver it's a problem but if
you're the President of the United
States or you're you're going to be the
president I say yeah let's not get nuts
there is a toxic culture in Hollywood a
hundred percent it's bad it's bad for
women it's bad for children there's a
lot of powerful people in LA that are
predators and that prey on vulnerable
people and those people have been
protected and many of those people have
built fortunes okay and they have mass
of mass great fortunes and with that
amount of money and clout and power
comes the ability to could continually
shield themselves from any
accountability we would know more about
who those people are except for Corey
Feldman tends to not ever get to the
names Corey Feldman is now promised to
out all the Hollywood pedophiles
forever and then every time he's
supposed to do it he just drops a new
single with the Angels so I could be
wrong on this we I guess we would know
who those people are he's always like
and I'm gonna announce every big bettor
piling Hollywood but before we do that
we got a new song and then he just
starts going into like you know so I was
a child actor I never succeeded and I
was great-looking as a kid I was
top-notch you know and I never got to a
point where I was like in in in in in or
around like these predators cuz they
want to went nuts they would had a field
day with me not now but then then they
would've had a field day with me now
they would just be like you know parked
my car or something
but back then I would have been a man
about town in this place but my parents
were inapt when I truly believed if they
could have they would have sold me into
sex slavery but being lazy boomers and
incapable of closing a deal
they did not I don't believe it was
immorality I believe it was that they
were literally stupid lazy and
good-for-nothing and that's probably the
only reason I was not passed all around
Hollywood I imagine that they they
probably were going to hand me off to a
director and got lost my mother at a
horrible sense of direction and I
imagined my boomer parents in Long
Island fighting all the way home about
not making the drop where they were
dropping me off I don't have any proof
of that
but I imagine that both of my parents
were pedophiles who tried to sell me to
Hollywood and failed even sadder I don't
know I don't have proof of that but
let's not get lost in that I would have
done better with competent they were not
good stewards of my career is my point
oh they actually they actually to their
credit shielded me from a lot of that
stuff like I remember I was going to
play in the city and my grandmother used
to stand outside the bathroom so like
nobody would come in and molest me which
was very nice of her you know the play
that I was doing was about there's more
molestation going on in the country than
I'd realized everybody's getting
molested this is a big problem and the
statistics on it are like staggering did
you know that especially during
quarantine it's highly underreported
right now it's it's [ __ ] up if you
really look into it what do you mean
teacher
were the ones who were really reporting
kids getting abused but now a kid
doesn't didn't discover that a kid's
abuse until he's taken to the emergency
room because has to be so bad
Wow yeah it was pretty depressing
reading about that the other night but
it's it's just skyrocketing and highly
underreported I mean it's a depressing
point I'm sorry it's not funny well no
that's what you add to the show off and
it's funny so it was a good it's nice to
take a break from what you usually add
which is non-stop hilarity that's why
you're here and I thank you for coming
in with something serious and said as
opposed to your usual festival of gags I
didn't give you good
you can't like oh I didn't you didn't
really get you talked about two children
that did it doesn't get reported until
they're in the emergency room from the
abuse what's not funny about that
what was it did I not was that not I
didn't know you spiked the ball you've
set it up for me I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
by not making that funnier the children
who are regularly abused now needing to
be abused severely and put in the
hospital so no I thank you for that and
I I apologize that I wasn't more
prepared to take that and run with it
because there's so many directions that
I could have gone to make that funny and
I appreciate the way you brought that
out it's true you know
so moving on but that's okay you you're
funny enough on the show where people
they don't want more funny out of you
they get enough funny out of you
sometimes they want you to have a fun
fact about you know the hospitalization
rate of abused children but it's a good
point what that you make is it kids
during the quarantine run their mouth
and some of them need to be dealt with
not raped but beaten now obviously we
don't we don't believe that these are
jokes and I know that see in five years
they're gonna get the podcast and when I
call my parents pedophiles or when I say
the kids need to get beaten in five
years it's just go or before that
they're just gonna be videos on Twitter
people gonna be like see see I mean
we're losing the whole idea of jokes and
that things are a joke you know what I
mean like Chris D'Elia was doing a bit
stood a bit and we've lost the idea of
that you do in a bed he's gone hey what
are you in high school
show me a ditz lol it's a bed he's doing
a joke it's a now it's a performance art
piece yes because it's not in the comedy
club but many great artists Andy Kaufman
and others tested the limits of art and
that is what Chris was doing he was
doing a performance art piece where he
was seeing what it would be like to kind
of be a pedophile he was saying if I
kind of if I were to ask a high schooler
what would this be like and I he was
probably doing it to raise awareness
because it is a problem and that's what
he was doing he was probably doing it
like that yeah but we've lost the
ability to take a joke in this country
no one can get the idea of what a bit is
he was doing it it was a gag he was
being a buffoon he was being a clown his
bit was he with message a girl and if
she was underage he'd go oh sad face and
then you know a few days later be like
are you still so are you still a [ __ ] a
joke do you see what I mean we're so
crazy Kevin Spacey was kidding he was it
was a joke like what
no one gets bits anymore Harvey
Weinstein was - he was a
prank he was trying to make the
actresses feel comfortable by raping
them because they were many of them
maybe was their first Pig movie and they
were a little nervous and he said it
would defuse the tension if ITIF I
pulled my dick out and wrestled this
woman in a hotel room do you see what I
mean that we're losing our ability to
really process good material who did the
best bit of the last century Oh Jay
Simpson OJ Simpson did the funniest joke
ever he cut it this is how funny he was
he decapitated the mother of his
children and a waiter as a bit yeah and
then got away with it
the ultimate punchline setup hmm a year
later punch not guilty yeah you want to
talk about a bit so that's my worry my
worry is that we are now involving the
FBI in something that should just kind
of be a laugh fest and you know
obviously I've not looked at the facts I
want to let everyone know that I've not
looked at the facts about anything it
just yeah
things seem to trend a certain way so
I've made I've made I've made some jokes
about the hold Dooley a situation you
know which is what you have to do you
know but it is shitty listen if you're
young and you're getting message on line
and asked for photos it's like it's a
[ __ ] up thing if this is what really
happened right right if this is really
what happened I don't know what happened
I'm not a detective but I believe all
women but not
read but oh but except for her but all
of the other ones and that one need a
Broderick who accused Bill Clinton of
rape I don't I don't believe her I don't
believe her because what I know about
the Clintons is they're beautiful people
who care about other people and wouldn't
rank them okay so that's where I'm at
we're the facts on this but there you
know there are things that are not
looking great and that's where we are
landing on this is that things are not
good all is not well from what I
understand you know what are you gonna
do there I go that's me leaving the
plane goes I look down
how'd you see China blows up Los Angeles
what a fun season finale for this Joe
China blows up I like China I mean these
DDoS attacks that are happening one of
them happened in Australia one of them
happened in America people think it
could be China they're speculating maybe
it's China compromising all these
systems could it be China I think so
yeah who hacked Sony was that China yeah
I believe so her Korea North Korea do
you think that they're just there these
are little tests little stress tests on
systems I do I've from what I've read
China has tested you know shooting down
satellites things like that wiping out
communication systems for like Air Force
bases to talk to each other things like
this yeah this is what they do I mean
they want it all China wants it all and
they're gonna get it probably yeah
I use these headphones in there great
okay they're rake on their wireless
earbuds from rake on you know rake on
air bud started half the price of other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
and they sound just as amazing as the
other top audio brands you know
newest model the everyday e25 earbuds
are their best ones yet with six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass and more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
rate cons wireless earbuds are so
comfortable perfect for conference calls
or binging podcasts unlike some of your
other wireless options rate kind of your
buds are both stylish and discreet with
no dangling wires or stems to distract
anyone during video calls you've heard
me talk about how this company was
co-founded by Ray Jane celebrities like
Snoop Dogg cardi B Melissa Etheridge
Brandi JR Smith or obsessed with retcons
pick up a parent see what all the hype
is about you use these right I like them
I like I like them a lot they're
charging case the whole thing the whole
thing you're easy they're sleek they're
you know call to add they're black black
lives matter you show people that but
the ears right it's important you know
call Ted now is the time to get the
latest and greatest from break on get
15% off your order at buy rake on Comm
slash tim by Raycom slash tim you get
50% off these were ready cheaper than
earbuds okay then this they're better
than your buds they're cheaper than ear
buds the whole thing I'm telling you
right now I use them I like them you
know I don't know what else to tell you
they're their ear buds if you need them
buy them if you don't need them buy them
understand because it helps us but it's
good if you if you if you have your buds
you like I like me your buds by retcons
have them as a backup if you don't use
them give them away to somebody if you
lose your ear buds guess what you get
new rate you do a new pair right there
for your rate god easy easy peasy
japanesey is that something we can still
say I don't think so but that was a fun
thing for my childhood note and you know
what no one associated that with
disrespect towards the Asian culture I
think it means that Asians are very like
they do things well right that's it
means everything works did you ever hear
that expression
easy peasy japanesey yeah yes what does
that mean they're I think they're very
well organized and orderly what's the
problem
right what's the issue
50% off your order by rake on.com slash
t I am that's by rake on RA Y Co n comm
slash t IM for 50% off an Vil rings and
bull rings I am a jeweler that's how I
make my money I'm a jeweler I have a
company called tools buy podcaster Tim
Dylan people go out and sell the jewels
and bring the truth they don't really
sell them they marry they marry a jewel
to a person they bring a jewel to a
person and that is great but now I'm
slinging rings anvil rings I partnered
with an amazing gentleman you know real
woodsman who lives in the woods and he
makes these rings and a little cabin
somewhere and you know he you know he
he's just a down-home country guy you
know he just lives in the middle of the
woods and I caught a wood cabin he's
like a welder you know he just gets it
you know what I mean he doesn't believe
in you know global warming or North
Korea or any of these things he's he's
just dedicated to his craft he's a
craftsman and they make rings from the
following unique materials meteorite
whiskey barrel Aaron wood natural shed
elk and deer antler titanium and
tungsten carbide Damascus steel Valyrian
steel Valyrian steel is from what's that
from Game of Thrones Valyrian steel I
believe it is from Game of Thrones
Valyrian steel yeah Game of Thrones
right yeah so this guy does Damascus
steel and he's phenomenal and I really
liked it he is do that I mean there's
over 500 five-star reviews every single
purchase includes free anvil ring
silicon activity band and an anvil rings
faux leather ring box if you were
commemorating an anniversary or
something I'm telling you this is a
great way to do it nobody has any money
right now the economy is crumbled okay
but I'll tell you right now you get
something very unique handcrafted for
somebody they will not forget it it's
really cool it's a mess it's something a
guy can give another guy without feeling
gay right yeah totally you
somebody gives you a ring it doesn't
mean they're gonna suck you off no but
it'd be nice if they did but you don't
have to
we offered they offer free cisors okay
for your [ __ ] and your hands so you can
you can you can get sized at your house
you can see what kind of hog you have
and what kind of finger yeah whatever
you want a wedding band anniversary band
you just want a ring that looks awesome
head to anvil rings com promo cookie I'm
telling you this guy all day he just
slaves over these ran I don't mean that
and I don't even mean to say that what
I'm saying is he's committed to the
Rings he just sits and he's a little
like thatched roof cottage in the middle
of nowhere and in a mystical Narnia type
world and he sits there with mr. Tumnus
the faun and they just he just makes the
goddamn rings you understand he makes
the ring and maybe there's a little
magic maybe there's a little magic to
the Rings maybe maybe you can't get
cancelled if you have one of these rings
how about that what if somebody's angry
because you said the word oriental in
2012 but then you flash them a ring of
Damascus steel and they go I understand
context and time and you don't get
cancelled an Vil rings calm use promo
code Tim to get 20% off a truly unique
ring I'm gonna get a ring the guy's
making me a ring and I'm gonna wear it
on the show
anvil rings com use promo code Tim T I
am to get 20% off a truly unique ring
I'm telling you right now if you want to
get a gift for somebody this is the gift
to get it's not expensive and its unique
and really cool and people it's a great
conversation starter people be like
where the [ __ ] did you get that and you
go I know a man that lives in the thick
of a wood and he makes rings all day for
mystical creatures that's what this
[ __ ] guy does and I respect the hell
out of him he's not in the rat race like
you he's sitting there crafting rings of
magical elements meteorite it probably
[ __ ] falls down into the forest he
got
then he makes a ring out of it you know
and then ships it to Sacramento
of course yes to ship it to pedestrian
places but he starts off sure he
probably makes these while the moonlight
is beautiful and bright and he probably
welds this by the pun to the light of
the Moon okay then he sends your rings
out tomorrow on New Jersey gogo loom for
you animal rings dot-com promo code Tim
you get 20% off unique ring that's a lot
of [ __ ] money that's a lot of [ __ ]
money okay this guy's a goddamn American
Hero
is the American he's in western Colorado
yeah he's in western Colorado and the
[ __ ] and in that whatever you know
whatever they got the desert what's that
candles Golden Colorado he's in a canyon
he's in a goddamn canyon making rings
with [ __ ] he's probably on peyote and
he's just making rings he's been on and
on at mescaline trip for 30 years in a
canyon in Colorado he's just running
around making he's probably making one
ring for the last 30 years he doesn't
know where to ship it that why he's
probably gonna we're probably getting
paid for these ads and peyote just just
cactus he just sent us a tub of
ayahuasca but no I'm kidding it's the
thriving it's a good business and you
should get involved with it right now
you know this drug addict is making
rings for people he's drinking moonshine
and he's just firing a rifle into the
air give him a goddamn ring to make okay
let him make a ring okay the guy sits
around all day reading about queueing on
on the computer and drinking bleach
order something from the man let him
work his wonders please okay
all day he just eats bacon grizzle
tries to prove the Mossad killed
Princess Diana will you get an Ironwood
ring from the man he has skills let him
use them please okay he's analyzing the
YouTube footage of the [ __ ] power7
all day while he eats Denny's he had
delivered let him make you a ring out of
natural shed elk antler Oh still a great
country and Vil rings calm use promo
code Tim to get 20% off a truly unique
ring you know maybe it maybe he could
carve some stuff into the ring you could
probably ask him yeah you know and rings
hold their value too if you think about
it and you get 20% off so if you think
about it it's a great way to say it they
hold their value if you think about it
because you could sell it I got a pawn
shop you know if you like you I could if
you needed to sell the ring you can sell
it at a point so what I like is you've
imagined someone's bought the ring and
their life is then become a horror and
they need to pawn it mm-hm and they can
what a great thought you just had
someone bought a ring yeah and then
maybe the relationship doesn't work out
sure and they become addicted to huffing
household cleaners and then they need to
sell their ring so they can get more
computer cleaner to Huff in a bag antler
rings dot-com promo code Tim to get 20%
off a truly unique ring thank you before
I go let me say this about the black
lives matter movement many of their
things I agree with by the way please
reform bla bla bla we all know this be a
little skeptical of a movement where a
lot of the leaders are vowed Marxists if
their own words they say that but it's
being supported by JPMorgan and Citibank
and all these big corporations be a
little skeptical that be a little
skeptical of a lot of corporations
embracing a movement that should be 100%
antithetical to
those people believe I'm not a Marxist
and I don't agree with that however I
have friends that are and I understand
their you know critique of capitalism I
think is very valid I don't think any of
their solutions or the majority of their
solutions are valid but when you start
thinking about why corporations are on
board with this movement and why
Hollywood people are on board with this
movement you start realizing that is
this is this the way to usher people
into an even worse police state than the
one that we were in before and in police
state that where you have massive
surveillance technology big tech you
know will the police be just new police
potentially I don't know you know I mean
this is something to think about you
know I mean you know the idea that any
of these corporations or any of these
people that have millions and millions
and tens of millions or hundreds of
millions billions of dollars are going
to you know adopt some type of you know
a narco communist reality it's just not
the case however who knows where this
will go and who knows where you know
where you know what form this ends up
taking and what freedoms you lose in the
process of thinking you are you know
being a revolutionary what freedoms
you're willing to give up and I think
that that that becomes a real you know
we've seen it under the guise of public
health people are willing to give up a
lot of freedom I understand that I gave
it up I said ah um I said hey this is
what we have to do but then you saw how
contact tracing was then used against
protesters right tracing people's phones
who they were with where they were then
that was used against protesters
keep keep in mind that these types of
things aren't necessarily going away you
rarely get those freedoms back that
youso either that you give up and I
think black lives matter is a lot of
very valuable important things to say
and they're there right about a lot
they're wrong about some things too
in my estimation of corn I'm a white guy
I'm not gonna believe that I know a lot
of black people that don't agree with
everything they believe either but just
beware of a protest movement that is
supported by all of the big corporations
and Hollywood beware of that a little
bit at least be a little skeptical
beyond guard a little bit
because that means that that movements
probably to some degree been co-opted
and it's it's probably going to a place
that might not be what the original
intenders thought and and and who knows
in the meantime what freedoms you lose
and my interest is in the freedom to
speak freely you know which i think is
on the chopping block that's going you
know I hope that's not the case but it
certainly seems like it's the case and
that's important to me it should be
important to you even though it's not
how you make your living it should be
important to you you know you should not
be you should not be fired from your job
for an expressing an opinion that is
unpopular or that people have decided
that black lives matter and JPMorgan
Chase have decided is the right opinion
to have and if you have a different
opinion you are fired from your job that
is not a value that I think is American
or you know any you know there's no
fairness there to me you know I'm not
with in reason you can't walk into your
job every day and be like I don't think
it was six million or what that but
within reason if you if you know one guy
I forget to who it was I was just
talking to somebody about it had a gun
he said if any of these looters get up
to my house I'm gonna defend my property
and he got fired and then Dick Wolf well
you know big Hollywood producer was like
justice unacceptable and and I mean you
know Dick Wolf made all his money with
[ __ ] cop shows which is hilarious but
like right there it's like you're well
you're losing your ability to speak if
you're gonna loot you could say the
people have freedom speech
but if they lose their entire life and
they're socially ostracized and they're
for saying something and by the way not
I'm gonna kill somebody not a threat
just saying I'm going to defend like you
didn't single somebody out and I'm gonna
get him just saying I'm gonna defend my
property if people come to try to
destroy it I'm going to defend it as is
my my right or what most people believe
is their right and then the guy gets
fired you go you wonder when does that
end when will that end will you always
have the right opinion will you always
be one step ahead of the mob that's
requiring you to have the right opinion
will you never slip up is that all of
these people that try to cancel other
people and they tried to wield the power
of this mob that's what JP Morgan is
doing that's what all these major mega
corporations are doing you're like let's
wield the anger and use the anger of the
mob and take it and make money funnel it
into something commercial and let's
support certain things and we're gonna
you know pay lip service to the movement
and then at the same time we're going to
figure out a way to brand whatever the
hell we're doing and and and keep it
keep our branding consistent with the
values of this movement even though what
we're doing might not be in line with
what they want you know you know we
might we'll be paying lip service to
them and at the same time doing things
that are not in line with you know what
people would consider reform so that's
just what you always have to be
skeptical I don't think we we live in a
time of religious belief where people
are really fired up and a lot some of
that is good passion is not a bad thing
it's something that's good it's why a
lot it's those surfers
something to be passionate about and had
great lives but you know instead of
doing that instead of doing the work to
figure out what you are passionate about
and where you see yourself and wait a
lot of people are just basically like I
am going to just adorn myself with
slogans you know I don't put BLM I don't
put any of that up because I don't need
to put up signs I put the black square
on Instagram up because I thought
everybody was doing that I didn't know
what that was and we found out five
minutes later was like the CIA did it ah
you know for whatever reason but I don't
I'm not always putting that stuff out
there because like I'm a human being
right I'm not like a brand it's like
people act like they're Starbucks like
human beings are acting like they are
like there are people that are just
putting out stuff every day almost like
they are afraid of their like for far
too long
you're this Ansel Elgort kid before he
got cancelled you look at his Instagram
he's like I'm spending the day educating
myself I'm spending the day reading and
figuring out what I can do I mean this
is this is so they don't come get ya how
did work God sell how did it work did it
not work as the great Charles Grodin and
Clifford said has something happened
but it's it's it's just to call the mob
you guys I'm spending my day educating
myself myself I'm gonna stop carving
swastikas into my arm for the day I'm
gonna start educating myself and
figuring out what I can do and I don't
mean any of that cuz I'm going to the
beach but I'm putting it on social media
don't come for me please don't that's
what it is
you can do those things you can just do
those
things but there's a weird vibe now
where you walk down the street you see
BLM and it's painted on the outside of
the business and it's painted because
they don't want to brick through the
window that's why it's painted there
it's just a strange thing oh I have to
say I have to put these letters on the
outside of my business unless
something's gonna happen I gotta put it
out there and it's been that and that's
odd to me and that that feeling is
strange we're like you have to you have
to agreed all of these things under the
threat of violence and that that's being
backed by mega corporations something to
think about doesn't mean the police are
not out of control does not mean police
do not need serious reforms doesn't mean
you can't take some of their money and
put it into things that will decrease
inequality doesn't mean the elites of
this country aren't the real looters
which they are does it mean they haven't
created this situation by you know
[ __ ] defunding everything and
hollowing every institution out and
creating a separate economic system and
a separate justice system I mean all of
that is true all of that is 100% true
but I still feel very uncomfortable with
this idea that people can just be fired
from their job and lose everything
because they express an opinion you know
that is pretty mainstream which is like
I'm gonna defend my property it's a
pretty mainstream opinion
well no Tim that's not the real issue
the real issue is duh the elites yeah
sure but if that was you and you lost
your [ __ ] job
that would be a real issue to you you
know I mean that's a fact you you know
and I could get accused all the time
people like but are you saying that 30
sjw's have as much power as Exxon mope
but that doesn't mean you can't
criticize something that's absurd
or that's it's going to an absurd place
that's what I'm saying I'm just it's
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable to walk
down the street and see boarded up
stores with BLM's spray-painted on the
outside so that they don't get bricks
through the window or they're not burned
down this is why and I know some of the
people that own these businesses they're
like well this is just what we gotta
have up there it doesn't sit well with
anybody that has any interest in civil
society and if people don't have an
interest in civil society and many of
them don't if they don't have an
interested suppose this I just know that
we're going to have a civil war and
maybe you win and maybe a don't but
we're gonna have serious violence and
you know it's it and the state is gonna
clamp down on everybody and that's when
they introduce a police state a total
surveillance state when we have total
chaos so the the forces that are
marching us toward total chaos is what I
was trying to get to the people that are
bringing us towards total chaos on both
sides by the way the people that want
that cast at hunger for it that long for
it are they so stupid do they think
they're gonna win or do some of those
people know what will come next which
will be a police state a surveillance
state and the government will use this
as an excuse to do a lot of things
they've probably always wanted to do you
know and that that's what I would look
around I see that I see that we're
heading towards a place where society is
gonna be even more closed people are
afraid to say anything and it's just a
bad situation and if that's the own if
we're if we don't speak to each other we
don't want to talk to each other the
only thing left is violence and so many
people right now think that's a good
idea they think it's just a time for
violence and that we've exhausted all
speech okay listen that's fine
if you think that you believe that you
you know you've given up on the whole
idea of any type of society you want to
just get rid of it
crepe but know what you doing know that
there will be a society that will emerge
from the ruins of whatever happens and
it will not it will be less free than it
is now dramatically less free
I don't think protesting is bad I don't
think economic boycotts are bad
I don't think putting pressure on the
government is bad I don't think any of
that is bad I think chaos invites more
chaos
I think that'll ultimately the response
to that will be Trump going full Hitler
or full dictator you know and and having
a a percentage of people in America on
his side because nobody wants chaos
nobody wants Anarchy children do
children don't want bedtimes and and you
know whatever and they want to you know
eat candy for dinner you know and
whatever you know but most adults don't
want chaos I know it's not cool to say
well the Guru bows to booze you know the
same people that were saying is saying
abolish the police were uploading photos
of bread two months ago they don't want
chaos they don't want a turkey they were
showing you they made a loaf of
sourdough two months ago and they were
proud of it they don't want anarchy
they're just too stupid to believe it's
possible they think it's a game they
think it's a fun game and they can
encourage people they're not out thrown
bricks they're at home tweeting and
bacon bread so this idea that they want
a [ __ ] and chaos and and and it's just
it's just kind of funny right the types
of people that are calling for no police
and no order are the
that would probably fair the worst in a
situation with with no police and no
order where you add literal vigilantes
you had militias you had warlords
because he's gonna be a power vacuum and
who's gonna fill a power vacuum you know
who do you think is gonna fill it you
know think it's gonna be filled it's
gonna be there's gonna be order in
society it's it's all about who's who's
order it's gonna be that's a fact but so
many people's country aren't adults you
know when you're a teenager you're
angsty you're upset you're depressed
you're anxious and then you grow up and
some people sometimes you grow up in an
hour sometimes you grow up in a day
sometimes you know it depends you know
but all growing up is is realizing that
nobody cares about you that is all
growing up is you realize no one really
cares no one can I used to let Mike
leave Mikey at home all the time and I'd
get home my dad wouldn't be home and I
wouldn't have my key and I forgot to
take it and my dad asked me five times
if I had it and then I would sit outside
my house and smoke cigarettes so my
[ __ ] dad came home and you know and
eventually I just realized that like oh
no one cares I'm an idiot and I should
just have checked before I left the
house I should have had Mikey I should
have prepared whatever could be your
homework could could be whatever all
being an adult is is realizing that your
feelings don't really matter that the
only thing that really matters is how
you carry yourself in the world right
doesn't matter how you're feeling inside
or what's upsetting you doesn't matter
what your past is or where you came from
it really matters like how you carry
yourself in the world despite all of
those things and adults realise that
then they look back at themselves at
teenage they're like I was a [ __ ] how
does a [ __ ] for no reason nobody
understood me
they don't get you wouldn't get it you
don't understand what it's like to grow
up in the suburbs to be white and want
people to understand you and then you
grow up and go oh no one gives a [ __ ]
about me no one cares
about me at all I don't I don't have
that many friends
and I don't need that many friends
people over the age of 30 with large
groups of friends I've said it before on
this show they're mentally unwell
they're mentally unwell if you're over
30 and you have 15 close friends you
belong in an asylum because you don't
have to I mean you it's just crazy it's
crazy having 15 close friends is is is
somebody who's in high school right you
know what I mean so the whole thing is
when you look at social media we've all
kind of regressed we're children
everybody's a child now everybody's into
feelings and and themselves and there's
no there's no idea that no one cares
Citibank doesn't catch hey if you're
Morgan doesn't care so making these
people you know put up your iconography
or put up letters you find comforting or
put up a pride flag or whatever they can
do the to present the optics that
they're your ally is utterly meaningless
fatuous means nothing and you would know
that how do you grown up you would know
that how do you grown up that's the
reality and if you were a grown up you
would do grown-up things you know and if
you still want to be a teenager if you
still want to be a teenager you can go
on Twitter you can [ __ ] tweet you can
[ __ ] do whatever you want to do you
know you could do everything to make
yourself feel good in the moment it's
true if you want to act like a sixteen
year old you can do all of those things
and I even know I know a guy that won't
hold that against you if you're a
teenager I know somebody that will hear
you out
and give you the time of day if you're a
passionate youngster but everybody else
grow up